uh good morning everyone um welcome back
to the lecture the lecture number four
of this course
so today uh now today this lecture is
going to be a follow-up from tacos
lecture uh a few a few hours ago so we
are going to continue discussing about
about geometric priors and how they
uh hopefully make a machine learn like
learning easier in high dimensions
all right
so today yeah in this lecture we are
going to
um first the first thing we are going to
discuss is
how
these ideas from symmetries and
invariances relate to the to the
problems that we discussed in the
lecture number two that
concern the curse of dimensionality then
we are going to
move from the notions of invariance to
notions of scale separation so we are
going to discuss another prior
and then we are going to combine these
two priors in variance and scale
separation into what we call the
geometric deep learning blueprint
okay so that's what we're going to do in
this hour
all right so let's start with the first
one
so
remember the goal
of machine learning in particular in the
case of supervised learning
is to
learn an unknown function f star right
so remember the notation is that this
function f star
is defined over a very very high
dimensional space x would be the space
of all possible images for example
and so um
remember
that uh one of the kind of the
conclusions that we had in the lecture
number two and that taco started to
discuss is that if we just stick with
this black box thinking that x is a very
high dimensional space well basically
there's nothing we can say right the
learning is always going to be
fundamentally hard unless we make more
assumptions and so in this
in this context but the kind of
assumptions that we make they rely on
what we call opening this box right so
try not treating the input space x as a
black box but seeing x as the space of
signals uh small x that map from a
geometric domain omega to some space of
channel right and here there's a little
illustration where what i mean right the
domain now becomes here in this
particular case a two-dimensional grid
okay so so the thing is that here
capital x is a high dimensional space
but the input space here that the
geometric domain omega is a low
dimensional space right in this
particular case it's just two dimensions
and so
once we have this domain this
two-dimensional like low-dimensional
structure or more generally we have a
like a domain and a mathematical logic
that is much simpler we can do many
things with it right and and and these
geometric domains they come with kind of
a natural class of transformation right
there's things that we can manipulate
like the objects in omega can be
manipulated in ways that are very very
simple for example if i have a
collection of elements in a set well
there's a transformation that is very
natural in a set that is just to shift
the elements right to permit the
elements or if i have a points here in
this grid in this two-dimensional grid i
can move the points right i can i could
translate
any pixel from one location in the
two-dimensional space to another
location
okay and i can do that either with the
rigid motion like a you know euclidean
transformations here or i can do it even
with what we call a warping or
differentiating right so every point
every pixel in my domain is moved in
another place
and what uh taco described discussed
this morning is that once i have once i
know once i have a collection of
transformations well i can suddenly
start to do very nice things right i can
compose them i can apply transformations
one after the other and these
transformations they form what we call a
group right there's a there's a
algebraic structure that emerges very
naturally
in this in this context
and so
here's another
very interesting thing that you can do
with these transformations and i also
think that taco discussed that is that
once i know how to move elements in my
geometric domain omega right like amount
like points in a grid or elements in a
set then i can i can upgrade i can kind
of
use these transformations to transform
much more complicated objects which are
the signals on the domain right like
these uh so in other words i can go from
a transformation that move things in my
low dimensional space omega to the same
transformation right that moves things
in a much much higher space right like
the space of signals that that live in
that domain and the natural way to
extend these transformations is by
composition right and so here the
example that you see is like let me see
this picture right so if you look at
here the right a transformation that is
just moving um pixels around right if i
apply this transformation now when i
have images right hopefully you should
be able to see that these are some
rotation that i can apply to my image or
i can apply some
some deformation writing as in this
video that you see right so so here's an
example of a transformation that is
defined in this two-dimensional grid
that now i can apply it to transform my
inputs in my high dimensional space okay
and and this
not only this the transformation that i
have in this high dimensional space is
linear okay and i think that taco uh
maybe gave you the the you know the the
right language for that is called a
group representation right so this is a
this is a transformation here using the
left-hand side that is linear with
respect to x
all right
so um
so now let's try to to like natural
first question is okay now we have this
invariance
um how can we connect the notion of
invariance with uh with a you know with
a statistical learning right with a with
a problem of learning that we discussed
uh two days ago
so remember we have this function that
we don't we we don't know and we want to
learn and we are trying to learn this
function within a class right this
capital f was a class of uh function as
a class of functions for example things
that we can parametrize with neural
networks
and so here's a promise right so so now
i i
i assume when we make this you know this
assumption that the function that we
don't know that we want to learn is
invariant with respect to some group
right so it means that for any input in
our space
and for any transformation in our group
the function
uh is the same
if we if we apply x if we apply the
group transformation to the any input
okay
so this is an assumption this is a kind
of a prior that uh i promise you right
so so so you know that this is true all
the time
so natural question if this is true
uh these are there are two natural
questions right so okay uh how can we
now leverage this this assumption in our
hypothesis class can we do better
uh now that we know this extra
information
and obviously it's like even if we can
do better can we do can we do good
enough so that we can break the course
of the nationality right like the the
you know the major issue that we had
where uh you know the the the any any
kind of quantitative guarantee was
always very hard to get in higher
dimensions
okay so is this clear
uh yeah and again please do not hesitate
to stop me for any questions because i i
don't see you in the camera so uh please
do not hesitate to interrupt
all right
uh so these are the two questions that
we are gonna study now
okay so first let's forget about the
algorithm let's forget about
implementing anything let's just think
about abstract like theoretical right so
how can we now use these invariants with
respect to this group of transformations
to do better machine learning right to
to learn more efficiently
so the first idea right is to use what
we call this smoothing operator like we
are going to use the group of
transformations to
have a way to smooth functions
and so
let's assume for simplicity that the
group is discrete right so we can just
you know like sum like go through the
group by just summing all the elements
and so given any function f this is this
is like the target function or like any
function that we want to parameterize in
our network we are we are going to
define its smooth version
as
the average of the function
over the elements of the group right so
in in coordinates if you think about
what happens here in this in this
equation for any given input x
the output of my of my hypothesis
is not going to be f of x but it's going
to be the average
over the what we call the group orbit
and what is the group orbit
is all the possible transformed versions
of x right so this is what you have here
in the in the right hand side right so
i'm basically
i have any function that you know
produces labels let's say that they have
a you know like i think uh you know alex
net or whatever right like any network
and rather than using the output of alex
net at this particular image i'm gonna
average over all the predictions that
the network does over all the possible
rotated versions of this image right
that's where this operator is like
so now i ask the question
if i apply this moving operator to my
function f star what do i get right so
remember that the the the assumption
that we have on f star is that it's
invariant
right so remember what is the definition
of invariance is that the function f
star
is the same at x or at any
transformation of x
so this means that the function f star
when i look at it along each of these
orbits
gives me something that is
constant right doesn't change
so what happens if you have a function
that is constant and you average it
nothing changes right
so a function that is constant along the
orbits if i do the average nothing
changes
okay
so this is a this is a
so now let's try to build on this
observation
okay so now well if i know that my
function uh target function doesn't
change by averaging
here's a natural idea right uh given any
hypothesis class this could be let's say
the family of you know fully connected
neural networks
we can make it invariant by applying the
smoothing operator right so any function
in my family now i'm gonna instead of
using it directly i'm gonna use the
smooth version of this function of this
function right
why because you know the target doesn't
change so so i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna consider it in my
hypothesis class
so here's an example right so let's
consider the domain you know the
discrete domain of the points right
let's say a one-dimensional grid
and here i'm considering as a group of
transformations that translates the
shifts okay so so this corresponds to
the the group that is called the cyclic
group of order d right and i i assume
that you know once you shift this point
the last point you go back at the
beginning
okay
and now i consider as my hypothesis
class
f
all the polynomials that i can build
with the coordinates
of degree key
and now
let me now let's think about what would
we get if we take this polynomials and
consider their smooth version
so
you know there's a question for you
right but
think about uh how you would now take a
take one of any one of these functions
and consider it smooth version right so
remember that a smooth version right it
should be invariant right with respect
to all the permitted all the
translations like all the shifts right
so so
think a little bit about how would that
do and obviously this moving operator if
you change the group right if you let's
say replace the group of shifts by maybe
a much larger group like the group of
all possible permutations
then this this function right that is a
you know this the smooth the invariant
function class will become small
right so here the the bottom line is
that if i had the larger that the group
of transformations right like the gra
the larger the the class of invariance
the smaller is going to be this set
right
so there's less and less invariant
functions right the uh you know the more
the larger the group is
i hope this is clear
okay and these are two uh little
exercises that i leave for for you if
you wanna if you wanna if you wanna try
to think about the answer
i'm ready i'm also of course available
in campus y
all right so now
let's try to uh
to argue the following right is that the
approximation error
is not affected
by
smoothing on the group right so i claim
that if now i given a target function f
star
if i try to minimize
the error right
on in my family class right in my
function class capital f
what i claim is that i pay no price if i
reduce the set reduce the hypothesis
space from capital f to its smooth
version
okay and why is that
well the reason why is that is that in
fact this operator
this moving operator is a projection
okay i'm just
essentially i'm the i'm decomposing the
space along the orbits and just keeping
the average along each orbit
so in fact it's an orthogonal projection
right and so i what i can do is that any
error any l2 error i can break it into
the air that i make in the range of the
operator
plus the error that i make in the
complement in the orthogonal complement
right and this is a
nothing else than the pythagoras theorem
right because this is an orthogonal
projector
and so because my now my function
f star is invariant
right
what i see is that because the function
is invariant
this term disappears right when i when i
replace
g by f star this term disappears so my
error that i make right has two
components
is the error that i make on the
invariant part plus
i
hit a price
how many variants
so obviously from this equation
you can almost
immediately see that i'm better off just
uh you know assuming by construction
that the yellow term here is zero right
that this term doesn't doesn't doesn't
appear
and so obviously
i
i have a i have something that looks
like a winning strategy here right
because i have a function class that the
one in green
that has the same error the same
approximation error and because
the green space is smaller than the blue
space because it's a projection
i have i will have smaller statistical
error right so i have the same
approximation error and smaller
statistical error so it means that it's
better
but the question is by how much
right is it actually
is it a gain that is minor that is
marginal or is it a gain that is
substantial
any questions so far
okay
okay so now let's try to do a little bit
of a
quantitative statements here this is
possibly the
maybe the the the most technical slide
of today so i hope bear with me
uh
so remember from uh from two um lectures
ago the class of functions that were
ellipses right that were just uh locally
regular right
and now we are gonna
yes so
there was a question come from campus
wire someone was asking perfect okay
please can you explain what is the
group's music operator
okay yes that's uh very important to
understand the
this concept yeah so let me go back to
the definition
[Music]
good so the smoothing of the group
smoothing operator is an is an operation
that i make to a hypothesis to a you
know to a function that maps input to my
machine learning model to the odd okay
and it's an operator that does the
following
here in this equation or maybe you can
look at this equation that is even more
clear is that
given an input x
i am going to
consider all the transformed versions of
x but this is the what what we call this
orbit look at this picture right
so almost think i think it has some kind
of data augmentation right so you have
all the possible transform version of
the input
then i'm going to apply my network my
hypothesis f to each of them and then
i'm going to take the average
that's the group smoothing operator
right
and this group of moving operator
has a has a immediate property there are
two things that that are important
the first one is that this is an
orthogonal projection right so you can
think about it that if i apply the
smoothing operator twice
i get the same thing right
you know if i smooth two times i get
exactly the same output right because
the function
right these orbits by definition of the
group right they are the same
irrespective of where i start
and the other property that is important
is that when my function f star is
invariant in the first place
right
then when i apply the smoothing
nothing changes right because if i have
a function that is already constant
along these orbits
a constant function
if i if i apply the average at every
point it doesn't change right because
the you know the function is already
constant
okay i hope that this is clarifying the
definition and the the concept of group
smoothing operator
very good
so now as i said i can i can consider
like a you know the smooth hypothesis
right foreign
is the cyclic group
cycle group so that was an example that
was the different axons
yeah so the cyclic group is a particular
group that is think about the
the you know like the arithmetic model
of d right so think about like let's say
the you know numbers like binary
arithmetic right like you have binary in
binary numbers right so zero plus zero
equals zero zero plus one equals one one
plus one equals zero right so this is an
example of a group where i can think
about this some kind of additive group
but the only difference is that it has a
kind of a periodic boundary condition
right as i can i can you know every time
i i arrive at the la at the largest
number i go back to the beginning right
that's what's called a secret group
any more questions
okay
so you can continue
continue perfect yes good
so i was
here
okay
but so this is uh this is the setup that
where now we are going to try to
quantify a little bit this game so
remember that we had this
space of a function that was very very
large the space of lipsticks functions
and the the conclusion from
lecture 2
was that this space of hypothesis was
far too large right in the sense that
there was no way we could guarantee that
we can learn efficient that we can learn
functions in this class with a number of
samples that is not exponential in
dimension right so it's like a massive
little it's a tool it's a set that is
very very large
so now let's try to go to to make it
smaller let's try to add this hypothesis
of environments let's try to see if we
can
suddenly start to learn with more
efficient like with smaller sample
complexity if we add invariance into the
slipsheets hypothesis
so now my hypothesis is that this
function f is going to be lip sheets
right but also it's going to be
invariant with respect to the with
respect to a group of transformations
right so it means essentially it means
that this function f of x minus f of x
prime right
if x and x prime are in nearby orbits
right then the value of the function
doesn't change too much
all right that's the that's the notion
of uh
lip sheets plus environment
so here's a result uh that we
we worked on with a couple of
collaborators from from my group
that says that okay if we now try to uh
use
uh you know learn with essentially with
the optimum model machine learning model
for learning ellipses functions which is
kernel methods and we use a kernel that
is invariant with the spectral accent of
g
indeed we can do better than if we don't
use the grouping variants right so so in
other words the this is the
generalization like this is the
the test error of of our learning is
gonna it's gonna it's gonna have a
a generalization error
that essentially uh
it's as if the algorithm instead of
using n number of samples was using n
times the size of the group
okay so in that sentence as if the
algorithm was is better right because as
it was using more data points right it's
a it's a
it's there's a gain in sample complexity
which is consistent with the intuition
that we have so far right that the
approximation error doesn't change and
the generalization error is has to be
better right so that's what we see here
but there's a big problem there's a
problem here right
is that even if this number here that
you see in blue is very large we said
it's an exponential in dimension
right this exponentially dimension is
going to be killed by this rate right so
here you see that the dimension is in
the denominator right
so if we have something here that is
exponential in d
this d here is going to be killed by
this d here
which means that the rate the gains
are like the rates in number of samples
is not going to change
okay so the rate of learning like the
the the generalization rate is still
cursed by dimension okay so the only
thing that invariants give us in this
context is again in the constants right
we can do better but the the kind of the
major problem that we had before still
remains right we still have this
very bad dependency on dimension for
this class of regulation
let me also say that the you know the
gains that we see here relative to not
using the invariance are real right so
so if you use a kernel that is not
invariant then actually you can you
cannot reach this generation error right
so there's a there's actually a
sharp contrast between invariant and
non-invariant kernels
okay so but the conclusion here right
is that
uh
if you use them if we if we're using
variants in our networks
uh we are going to do better that's
that's a guarantee that i tell you but
so there's a there's an improvement in
sample complexity
but
there's two uh things that that are you
know that we still need to address the
first one
is that it's not sufficient right it's
necessary right uh but it's not
sufficient right we need some other tool
to say to guarantee that we can learn
with a number of samples that is not
that does not blow up with the dimension
right there's something missing what is
missing
and the other right is that so far this
analysis that we have made right we have
we have made everything from this
smoothing operator right and this seems
like a kind of a very abstract concept
right there's no there's no there's no
easy recipe for implementing this
operator in practice in your algorithm
in your computer right so how can we
build these invariants in a way that is
efficient right that is a you know that
we can implement and this thing runs
efficiently okay so these are the two
important things that we are going to
discuss next
a good time also not to make a pause and
ask for questions
because i cannot access campus wire in
real time so yeah if there's some
questions either here on campus wire
happy to to address them now
otherwise i will move on
yeah please i think um we can move ahead
there's no questions right now perfect
perfect thank you
all right so now let's move to the to
the second part of the lecture
which is uh addressing the missing
ingredient right which is the notion of
scale multi-scale separation
okay and so if you think about why deep
learning works and what is the kind of
the secret sauce of these architectures
and you go to you know to the lectures
of the
the you know one like the pioneers of
the field like joshua benjo or lagun
you see that their uh arguments
uh they all involve this notion of
compositionality right like the fact
that you can actually break a very
complicated input right like a kind of
image that has millions of pixels
you can process it in ways that are step
by step right so first you can focus on
maybe local features right what they
call these low level features then these
low-level features are combined into
more complicated structures and so on
and so forth right and in fact
this is a very intuitive idea right that
that
you know it's it's it's present in in
deep learning but of course it was
present in many many other areas before
right like even people doing computer
vision have exploited this idea and in
fact this is an idea right this
compositionality is an idea that is in a
sense at the core of science on physics
right so like the idea that we can
process very complicated phenomena by
breaking the problem into different
steps right like first you know let's
let's look for example at biology okay
or uh yeah exactly biology or any kind
of like a chemical process right so so
there's actually ways in which you can
first understand how you know how things
behave at the level of uh
sub atoms using quantum mechanics then
at some point you need to understand a
little bit of chemistry right maybe at
this level and then at some point you
need to start to start understanding
things about biology right and like how
molecules you know become proteins and
then proteins become cells and then you
see what you see the idea right and this
idea is is present in many many areas of
physics like when people study
turbulence or when people study like a
percolation phenomena critical phenomena
even in you know many areas of data
science we also have this idea
okay so
a complicated when we have when we are
facing a complicated problem that has
many dimensions natural idea in science
try to break it into into smaller pieces
very natural
so in our context right uh we need to we
can formalize this intuition uh with
what we call the multi-resolution
analysis okay and uh for simplicity i'm
gonna just uh you know illustrate this
principle uh using a two-dimensional
grid the grid that you see here on the
on the right
okay
so
i think that the main idea right is that
if i have any signal or any structure
that lives in this
rectangular grid omega
there's a
the the idea that i want to communicate
that i want you to get like division is
that i can always
change the resolution right i can
preserve the information that i see by
changing the resolution right you do
this all the time when you have a you
know you take a picture with your phone
or you know and then you want to send it
to your friends you can send it you can
change you can choose the resolution
right you can either send it in full
resolution it's going to be very you
know it's going to take a long time it's
going to be it's going to
take a lot of space or you can compress
it and make it smaller
so this is actually instantiated uh
mathematically in what we call a
multi-resolution analysis right so what
is a multi-resolution analysis like you
know broadly speaking is that it's an
it's a process by which you take any
signal like any image right it's like
this signal that lives in this
two-dimensional grid and we can
decompose it into a signal that lives in
a in a coarser resolution right like
here the the idea that i try to
illustrate is this like resolution on
orange has less pixels than the result
than the gradient grain right
and so i can express a
an original signal x in terms of the
course version right but of course when
i when i take a when i when i go from
the gray
cell like grid to the orange grid i'm
throwing information right i'm you know
i'm using less number of pixels so the
multi-resolution analysis what it does
is it also preserves keeps the details
at the given resolution omega that i
need to reconstruct so it's really this
process where i start from this like
original image here
and then i break it into the low
resolution version that is this one here
and then
i need to preserve i need to keep the
information that i that i need to go
backwards right to go from the course
resolution to the final resolution so in
other words i need to preserve the
details right that are encoded in this
in this image here and this image here
and these details
are what is captured by what we call
wavelets right the wavelets
are
essentially a bunch of filters that
extract that really do this
decomposition for you right and this is
actually uh
something that we are going to
discuss with a little bit more detail in
lecture seven when we are going to talk
about grids
but the key property that for now you
need to you know i want you to to
remember is that these filters right
this little these wavelets they're
they're think about these as little
waves that are localized in space right
right it's very different from a sine
and cosine which are waves that keep
going you know forever wavelets have a
different properties that there's kind
of little waves like
waves that are localized in space
and this is actually uh
[Music]
these web at the compositions are very
important in many areas of you know
might you know beyond computer vision
but they are used in many many areas of
science right
um
anyway
all right so what is the link between uh
this decomposition of you know this way
of thinking about images in terms of
different resolutions and or learning
problem
so here's an example right and and and
this is really what is what we call the
scale separation prime okay so let's see
how the resolution of the input
can give us a different category of
price okay
so
first let's make the assumption that the
target function that we don't know right
f star
has the property has a following
property is that the function i need to
learn and in fact i can i could also
learn it directly from the course
resolution right so i don't need to look
at the image at full resolution to
understand the function so here's an
example
let's say that we have a problem where f
star of x just encodes the probability
that uh like whether i'm in a beach or
in a month
right given the image i just need to
guess whether it's a beach or it's a
month
okay so this seems to be a fun a
function f star
perhaps i don't need to get all the
details i don't need to know you know i
don't need to see all the waves in the
sea and i don't need to see all the
boats in the in the beach and i don't
need to see all the trees in the
mountain to know that it's a mountain or
a beach right so in other words if now i
remove the details and i just look at
the course scale right for like here
well i guess that we are you can all
still tell that in the top we have a we
have a beach right and in the bottom we
have a mountain right
so here's an example where the core
scales dominate right so here i'm in a
problem where essentially to approximate
this function as star i don't need to
think about the function x like the
input x as being high resolution right
so i can you know indeed i can just
focus on the on the right hand side and
what is the advantage of thinking of the
function in terms of the low resolution
well the lower resolution has much much
less pixels right it has a much smaller
number of pixels and so in that sense
the number of you know the the the
number of like the dimension of the
input is much reduced right so the
course of dimensionality in the tenth is
is reduced
just because i i can you know replace
the input by something that has much
smaller dimensionality
okay this is example clear
okay here's another example for you and
obviously sorry sorry but obviously this
assumption right that that i told you
that you know that i can always kill the
high frequencies it's not true in
general right this is only true in
certain cases right so so
if i think for example as another
example the you know recognizing this
emit stations right
so you can all uh look at the mnist
digits here right and probably recognize
the the digit but if i blur right so if
i remo remove the high frequencies right
as i did here in the in the right panel
uh you know for me it's impossible to
tell what is the digit
okay
so what it means is that this is a this
is this is a this assumption that i just
made about the you know this example of
the beach and the
and the mountain is a very strong
assumption right it's i mean this cannot
be the
the basis right of of uh you know
geometric deep learn right uh we need to
be careful
so here's another flavor of this
equation right so there's another thing
that we can assume
right instead
that the target function
i can construct it i can approximate it
in a way that i can think it as a linear
combination
of
functions g
that instead of depending on the full
image they only depend on local local
patches of the input right this is an
example
of this texture that i showed here right
so if you want to you know separate
between a brick wall and a patch of
grass
well i guess if you just extract a
couple of windows from the brick wall
and a couple of windows from the patch
of grass you can already see right
that
you can already see that you know that
you can separate this to these two
clusters right you don't need to see the
whole thing to realize that it's a grass
or a brick right you can only look at
local scales
okay
so this is an example another example
where we can still we can also break the
course of dimensionality right that's
because obviously here the dimension
that matters the dimension that matters
is the dimension of the patch of the
yellow patch doesn't matter the
dimension of the whole thing
okay
so here's an another example where we
can still avoid this course of
dimensionality
by making this assumption
again is this assumption realistic for
any general problem
what do you think
well this seems pretty strong right this
so this example works for
the case of these two classes these two
textures but probably doesn't work in
general right and here's an example uh
okay so actually sorry before showing
the things where it doesn't work this
assumption is in fact uh
also quite used in many problems in
physics right like this locality right
the fact that the local interactions
dominate is a principle that is very
common right in many areas of science
but of course it's also strong
assumption right here's like a little
example that i that i took from from
this
paper by turk where you know if you just
rely on the texture on local properties
right you are missing kind of the global
appearance of the problem like
you can in a sense build examples where
you still need to see all the image at
once to realize what happens right so
what we see here is that there are kind
of different extremes right like that
either we
make an assumption that the course
scales are the only thing that matters
and then we can see that the problem is
easy or we can say that the local skills
are the only thing that matters and then
the problem is also easy but neither of
these two assumptions seems to be
you know seems to be realistic enough
right there's always problems where none
of this none of these assumptions is
going to be true
so
what we can do
is in a sense more generally we can
consider kind of a mix of the two right
so we can consider a model that this is
like this notion of compositional model
right we can try to think about our
function f right that we are trying to
learn as a composition of two functions
okay so first we have a step that we
call this p like a coarsening right that
is what the role of this step is to
reduce the size of the grid right or the
the reduce the corson the domain omega
okay
and then once we are in a course domain
omega the idea is that we are already in
a regime where the curse of
dimensionality
is somehow avoided right so so um we can
now learn in this this function f tilde
hopefully with a number of with a simple
complexity that is not as you know bad
as the original domain
okay and the key point right is that in
general we need these two guys to be
trainable right the assumption that i
made before like the two extremes where
in one extreme i just told you that this
object here this p
is actually a linear coarsening that
there's no no training that was the
first example and in the second example
i just gave an example where this f
tilde was just like a like an average
like a global pulling like an average
pooling without anything else okay so in
general we are going to be needing uh
you know non-linear models that are
trainable in both of these steps
okay
is this is this a separation is this
skull separation prior
clear any questions
otherwise i will move on
okay so natural question of course is
okay now we have introduced this
framework that is this model to
express to learn functions as a
composition why is the composition more
efficient okay and this is the again the
intuition the intuitive idea that you
know joshua yan and everyone has been uh
developing so
there's actually um
several frameworks where we can study
this question of a benefit of
composition quite precisely okay
so for example
in you know dynamic programming
we have this framework of divide and
conquer i like this strategy to solve
like algorithmic tasks by breaking them
into smaller tasks and then aggregating
right so this in many many you know for
many algorithmic problems
you know dynamic programming is an
example where where we get basically
best
you know good efficiency
there in fact
but in fact in the context of learning
these benefits of composition are i
would say it's fair to say that they're
still not completely well understood
right so we have intuition that these
these models
should be more efficient but we don't
have very mature math to explain why
okay and this is in a sense a work in
progress
okay
but what we are gonna what was still
what we're gonna settle is that the in
any case this prior of scale separation
this view of looking at the problem uh
looking at parameterizing functions as a
composition
uh in a sense it's it can be combined
very naturally with the with the other
prior which is the prior of symmetry
okay and so that's what we are going to
see
right
now okay that's the third part
which is the blueprint the geometric
deep learning blueprint okay i will
pause again before moving into the last
part for if there's any question
okay
so now that we have seen the two
uh
fundamental geometric priors like
invariant in first place and then scale
separation in the other place
let's try to see how we can combine them
okay into uh into a plur into another
kind of into an architecture or
blueprint that we can use across many
many many different domains
okay
so remember the wish lists that we want
right so we want the our function class
to be invariant to the transformations
just because we have seen that it always
helps
we want to have multi-skill structure
because we need it you know to break
their course of dimensionality but of
course we want this class of hypothesis
to be very rich right to be very
expressive right we want to be able to
to approximate
like a large class of target functions
okay so how can we build an architecture
that satisfies these three properties
let's start
with
linear functions by linear impairments
so
we can first try to understand
uh try to try to enumerate or uh yeah
like to describe all the possible
environments with respect to a group
okay that are linear
so how many are there
in fact there are not so many
okay
there's
essentially only one operator that is
linear and invariant to the group and
this is exactly the operator that we
just saw before right this is the
basically the average along the orbit
okay
in fact you can see that any operator
that is any operator f
that is both linear and invariant
in fact has to be a function of the
group average always okay and you can
see it here there's basically two two
steps here right so like in the first
step here the first equality we are
using the fact that it's invariant
and in the second equality
we are using the fact that f is linear
okay so you can see that the you know
the object that appears here is the
group average
okay so the group average
is basically the only linear operator
that gives us invariance to the group
but of course this is not an operator
that we can use
uh for many things right because it's
it's an operator it's very lossy imagine
here right in this example of the faces
right if i look at the average of all
these all of these faces right across
all rotations
i'm probably going to be losing all the
information i care about
okay
so clearly we need to have something
that complements this average
so how can we complement it
so it turns out that the the natural way
to complement that the right way to
complement
invariance
is by looking at linear equivalence okay
and i believe that taco already
described
what equivariance mean right but just
for for security let me just recall the
definition right so if i have a group
that is acting on both the input and the
output of this mapping right mapping b
then this mapping is equivariant if
essentially the group action commutes
with b right so if i apply the
transformation in the inputs right here
and i apply b
i get the same thing as if i first apply
b
and then apply the transformation in the
output
okay
and there's many many examples i mean
this concept of equivalence is central
it's going to be very very central in
this course right we are going to see it
again and again and again and again
so now
uh
so so uh let's see what i can do with
linear equivalence okay so uh and for
that you might ask okay but remember
that what we had the goal we had at the
end of the day is to learn invariant
function right that's our that was our
wish list right if we go back here the
wish list was to get invariants right
so what is the relationship between
equivalence and invariance
so you might say
okay maybe i can i can take one of these
guys that is equivariant and then
compose it
with a group average right do i get
something different
so if i take a linear equivariance and
then i apply the linear invariant does
it help
well you can already see the answer
right it doesn't help
why
do you think it doesn't help i
combine so i i the goal here is to build
more in variance right and so i
i suggest that maybe we can look at
equivalence
so if i take one mapping that is
equivalent with g
that is linear and i compose it with a
linear invariant that's the one that you
had before this this group average
do i get
something
new right do i get like a new invariant
that they didn't have before
and the answer
is no right just because
when i compose a linear equivalent with
a linear invariant
i still have a mapping that is linear
right the composition of two linear maps
is still linear
and we just saw in the previous
slide right that basically the only
linear the only linear invariant is the
average
okay so
if i start composing operators that are
lin operators that are linear
i'm not going to get any more
expressivity
okay
so the alternative right and i guess
that this is hinting the answer is that
i need to go non-linear right we need
something that break you know that that
we need something that makes the
operator nonlinear
uh but also of course we need we need to
apply something non-linear that doesn't
break all the other properties that we
are trying to build i think particular
doesn't break the invariant of the
equivalence
and so
um
what is like the answer here is to
consider
operators that are non-linear
but that
that only acts element-wise right so
these are transformations that we call
raw
that map images to images
in a way
that the
transformed image at pixel u
is only a function
of the image of the value of the image
at pixel u right so here's an example to
illustrate what i mean first think about
an operator that changes the color
right
of each of each pixel
this transformation can be nonlinear can
be anything you want
but of course it's a transformation that
only that looks pixel pixel one by one
and applies the same mapping pixel after
pixel right it doesn't it doesn't depend
on the
ensemble of pixels at the same time
and so now i'm in business right because
now what happens if i take a mapping b
that is linear and equivalent to g
and i compose it with one of these guys
one of these element element-wise
nonlinear mappings
i have a new operator this b tilde
and i claim that this operator
is still equivalent
okay
and why would that be
why is this operator equivalent after
the non-linearity well because of this
property right remember
that
uh
an equivariant function right is
to verify with variance i need to make
sure that if i apply a group
transformation right so on before b
tilde i get the same thing if as if i
apply the group transformation after b
tilde
but because this
operator b
is equivariant and this operator row
only looks at pixels individually right
i get this computation property right
and i think this is an important edges
size
that i encourage you to
to to verify by yourself okay
and so
the point here is that now we are kind
of culminating
into the blueprint
is that now we can we have uh we have
introdu we have now at our disposal
kind of three important building blocks
right let's just focus on these three
for now
okay the first one
is
if we can take an uh
operator that is linear and equivalent
with respect to the sum group g
then i can consider a family of
operators that are non-linear but
element-wise
okay
and then i have an operator that is
invariant with respect to g that can be
linear right this is a global problem
okay so now
the point is that if i have these
operators
i can start building combining them
composing with each other so i can start
creating a very very rich family
of transformations
right that satisfy my wish list okay
because from what i said if i take a
green okay that is green and i compose
it with a gray that is
blue
i still get something that is equivalent
right and if now i compose it with
something that is orange i get a new
invariant that is different right from
the original pooling okay because
because now the non-linearity is really
introducing other information
okay
and the the important point that i want
to stress here is that the way we define
these operations is very general right
in the sense that we can apply it for
many many versions of this domain right
so depending on the domain omega and the
group of transformations g
right here here's a recipe where the
only thing that we need is to understand
the class of linear equivalence
of that class right so given an omega
and a group we just need to understand
the class of linear equivalence and it
turns out that this is something that we
can do
um
in many many different domains right
this is like a little diagram and here's
an example right of the different
combinations sorry of the domain omega
and the group g
okay so if we take as the main grid and
we look at the translations
the blueprint
you know
gives us convolutional neural networks
if we take rotations on the sphere we
get the spherical networks et cetera et
cetera et cetera right so the same
principle that i just described which is
first understand the class of linear
equivalence
and then compose them with element-wise
non-linearities and keep composing
this gives all these different model
architectures here right and they are
all following the same principle
all right
just to
to summarize what we discussed today and
then we can have spend some minutes for
questions
so
what we have discussed is is two uh
geometric priors right the the
invariance with respect to some group of
transformations and then the scale
separation okay
and and these two priors have to be
combined right so if we don't
combine them
a priority there's no hope that we can
learn in high dimensions
okay
and so what we have seen is that uh
through this notion of grouping variance
and equivariance we can produce an
architecture that is this geometric this
gdl blueprint that is a is a kind of a
first principles architecture right is a
way to construct representations that
are have all the properties that we want
namely that they are they respect the
multiscale uh prior they are respecting
the invariance prior and that they can
be very expressive right that they can
approximate very complicated structures
so what we are going to discuss in the
next lectures by my colleagues by peter
taco and also michael and myself
is that we are going to now
in the next lectures look at this very
general blueprint and make it concrete
under different domains uh and we are
going to basically see how
each domain brings its own specific uh
properties right so so
here in other words in the surface you
might you might see that all these
architectures are the same right they
are basically have exactly the same
structure well because the grid the
sphere and this
and these groups have some different
properties
these different different in the domain
and the group are going to
induce difference in the architecture
and this is what we are going to
describe in the next lectures
so
now this is the end of my presentation
and i'm happy to take questions